tonight's game look
i said in the aftermath of the monday
night classic that it's going to make us
anticipate
more football it's the perfect way to
set the table for the last three weeks
of the season and then i
look at tonight's game and i think
yeah it's really not getting me all that
excited for tonight's game i mean
come on let's we're not going to be uh
intellectually dishonest to the audience
and
try to tell them this is some great
matchup the raiders are down to their
last chance basically the chargers are
cooked
but you know the the raiders could blow
this that that's why you watch it
there's a chance the raiders are just
going to
self-select they're going to take
themselves out of the mix
for the seventh spot in the afc by by
tripping over their shoelaces
and and losing at home to a division
rival chris
well i mean who knows with the raiders
right now right i mean they're kind of a
team in like a free fall for the last
few weeks
easily easily if it isn't for the
dumbest defensive call
in the you know 21st century to this
point
they've lost four in a row i mean that
that's simply how it is and then of
course you talk about
firing a defensive coordinator on a
sunday evening
right on the short week they got a bunch
of players some good football players
again not going to be able to play
tonight not available
so i i mean again
i think it's fun because like what
you're saying it's a little bit it
seems like it's ripe for an upset and
also john gruden and derek carr is
always good theater
and the other guy on the other side
justin herbert i'm always excited to see
him throw lasers all over the field so
you know from that standpoint it does
add some excitement here and there's
some good players on the field i think
it should be a good watch because
still like you're saying with all that's
going on the raiders they got a chance
here and they're fighting for something
according to points bet the raiders are
favored by three and it's the highest
over under of the week at 53.5
we are still spoiled by the 89 points
that were scored on monday night so even
if there's
60 it will be two-thirds of what we saw
most recently and
and that that's the problem the bar was
set so high on monday night it's going
to be hard four games this week to live
up to it especially a game between two
teams where we look at it we just kind
of say
but uh there is drama that the raiders
with the turmoil the firing of paul
gunther the defensive coordinator
abruptly after
last sunday night's loss to the cult
sunday afternoon the firing happened on
sunday night and then you have to turn
it around
and and get ready to go on thursday
night with rod marinelli as the new
defensive coordinator
good news for the raiders josh jacobs
their star running back is not on the
final injury report that means he's good
to go
but four raiders defensive starters are
out
safety jonathan abram defensive end
cleveland farrell
cornerback damon arnett and linebacker
nicholas tomorrow oh and on top of all
that henry ruggs
star rookie receiver on the covet 19
reserve list so
a few men down for the raiders as they
go into this must win game
yeah it's it's it seems like when you
just kind of go through all the story
lines
and it's thursday night football and
yeah i know the game's in las vegas but
that doesn't matter it just
it seems primed for an upset it really
does it just seems like it's set up that
way
you know you never know with thursday
night but you know to
the chargers anthony lynn you know he's
not sure where the status is
of his career is here right now so you
know they're going to be fighting for
something as far as
he's concerned he's going to have an
edge about him hoping that
hey can can i can we get three wins at
the end of the year that maybe saved my
job
give me a better you know perception in
the media with the fan base because of
some of the clock management issues and
all of those type of things this year
i think that's a very real aspect of
this as well let alone really mike
this is the crazy thing about the
chargers i mean when you really break it
down
and you start to go position by position
and
unit by unit you start to go well the
chargers are every bit as good as the
raiders
you know the offense can can do it all
i'm going to give the advantage probably
to the raiders when healthy
but the defense there's no doubt that
the chargers are better on that side of
the ball and
you know the records look a little
little you know different
but i think the the the actual reality
on the field is a lot closer than the
records say and i think that could lead
to
good tv tonight john gruden has been
back as coach of the raiders now for
three seasons four and 12 his first year
with a point differential of negative
177.
seven and nine last year with a point
differential of
minus 106 this year
seven and six point differential of
minus 41 for a team
with a winning record that is a little
bit on the odd side
and i know he signed that much-hyped
10-year 100 million dollar contract
although
from the get-go there were questions
about how much of it's really guaranteed
and
how much of it's front loaded how much
it's backloaded is it really what it
seems to be and
frankly when when we know as we tend to
hear behind the scenes that there are
other coaches making a hell of a lot
more than that it doesn't sound as
impressive as it did three years ago but
i remember how we were blown away by the
commitment that was made by mark davis
you just have to wonder number one
at what point is it no longer
cost prohibitive to move on from john
gruden if that's what mark davis decides
to do and number two
at what point would mark davis just
write a check if he becomes exasperated
with where the team is now
he was so smitten with the idea of
bringing gruden back i don't think he
falls
out of love with him after only three
years
but at some point chris pointed
questions have to
be thrown in the direction of john
gruden who
frankly since right place right
time super bowl win 2002 with the tampa
bay buccaneers you look at the
at the career accomplishments and
there's and hey why are you guys always
so negative why is everybody so negative
well
you've lost more than you've won as it
relates to the ultimate pass fail of
getting to the playoffs i'm gonna pull
up his full career record here
he's probably on the right side of 500
but if he is it's not by much
and he hasn't been to the playoffs many
times since winning that super bowl
18 years ago no mike i mean
you i i can't really argue a lot of that
i mean really i mean yeah the the
the results on the field maybe don't
match the perception of
what we really think of him or how we
view john gruden
because he is a little bit of an
offensive genius of course in so many
ways the personality the charisma
all that adds to the lure of gruden
right and maybe
yeah maybe makes us think he's better
than he is to a degree
uh in a lot of our eyes but you know
i'll say this
i don't think we're anywhere near having
that conversation with the las vegas
raiders right now i
i don't i mean really i think the
raiders are on the right track
i mean again i think from where the team
was when he took over
and how crappy it is he's really
as as we were saying a few weeks ago
that he's built a team that in some ways
can compete with the kansas city chiefs
no they're not perfect yet
he's got the offensive side of the ball
close to perfect and where he wants it
now it's the defense and he's got some
pieces in the defense the secondary
great
but as we talked about you know the
other day when we heard about the paul
gunther this is the next thing for the
raiders football team this offseason
is front seven front seven front seven
and i think when they get that
they'll be a total football team to
where we'll see a little bit better
results on the field but i think all in
all
things are still on the up and up he is
john gruden he does bring
you know the spotlight to the las vegas
raiders and i think mark davis
just just not not knowing or hearing the
rumors about his financial situation i
would have a hard time thinking he's
going to cut that type of check and cut
ties with john gruden at this point
anyways
first of all you don't need a spotlight
to be brought when the name is las vegas
raiders
first of all the spotlight is already
there when it's las vegas raiders
second of all 63 and 78
is john gruden's record since the super
bowl
year of 2002. chris he hasn't won a
playoff game
since super bowl 37
that was won by the tampa bay buccaneers
so i
if it was anybody else if it was anyone
not named john gruden
we'd be saying he's got to go we'd be
saying it's not working
we'd be saying it's over we'd be saying
why did you leave the broadcast booth
what was wrong with you what were you
thinking you know there's a lot of hype
there's a lot of smoke and mirrors
there's a lot of tough talk and scowling
that has fueled this guy's perception
that he's a great coach
you can't say he's a great coach when
you're 63 and 78
since 2003 chris oh i
i understand i'm i i get that i'm not
going to say he's a great coach
i think he's a real good coach he's just
he's a capable of winning a super bowl
type of coach
i do think that's you know still still
very much in the reality of john gurdan
and you know seven and nine last year
where they are right now at seven and
six some bumpy road
early on in the oakland with the oakland
raiders because of some of the contract
situations and all that but he's righted
the ship
they've done a lot of really good things
and
we still don't know if they might not
make the playoffs this year
so let's not jump the gun on that type
of conversation
and i think at the very least like if
mark davis who i think is a pretty smart
guy and realistic been around football
his whole life
realizes that when john gruden took this
team over
it was one of the crappier teams in
football and it needed a lot of work
so this is the first year he should have
expected anything
as far as you know competitions
concerned about being in the playoff
race
he's getting that yeah they've faltered
as of late it doesn't look good
but i don't think we're anywhere near
having that conversation about gruden
yet
first of all you would not bet your
rolls-royce on the raiders getting to
the playoffs this year i know you
no i would not i'm just saying they're
in the midst of it right right
second i don't have rolls royce i don't
have your house no you have you have a
bentley
second of all yeah there's a lot of
rolls royces rolling around here in west
virginia
second of all look at the other coaches
who have come in with as little or less
in the cupboard over the past few years
and gotten to the playoffs look at what
ron rivera is doing in washington i know
that the division
stinks but look at what he's doing with
alex smith
and i know he's blessed with a great
front seven but we didn't expect
anything out of washington this year
look at what joe judge is doing with the
giants we didn't expect a damn thing out
of the giants this year
look at what kevin stefanski did with
the chronically
underachieving cleveland browns he's got
them on the brink of the postseason so
these arguments that well he needs more
time he needs more time
this isn't 1975 where you come in with a
five-year plan
there are guys all around the league who
are turning bad teams around
quickly andy reid when he got to kansas
city in 2013
he instantly turned around an
underachieving team and they've never
looked back
so i'm i'm i'm just look
i got nothing against so what do you
think you think is hot seat time like if
they don't make them
no i think i think if i think if it was
anybody
but john gruden it would be hot seat
time that's what's amazing to me
this urban legend has grown up over the
past 15 years
20 years that john gruden is a modern
day vince lombardi
and the results don't back it up and no
one will
say it that's what's amazing no
one will say it he's not a great coach
he's barely a good coach he's arguably a
mediocre to average coach
and he's willing to call out anyone else
who isn't getting it done and do that
whole
two-faced thing which is fitting today
since half your face is blue and half
your face is white
but you know you know that's it's funny
it's funny somebody told me the other
day well you know what gruden does
gruden
gruden will say uh you know you're my
guy you're my guy you're my guy and then
the minute you walk away
he's bad mouth and it's like i work with
chris sims i know that i've known it for
three and a half years
that's baked that's baked into the cake
that's john gruden's dna
right how many other coaches get away
with being that way and no one ever
calls them out it's just amazing to me
because he was
pretty good on tv not spectacular not
not his i mean i guess you know
it depends on who you're comparing him
to but there's just this this
john gruden is vince lombardi thing and
there's an override
and let's i mean you flip flip-flop flip
i mean we're talking about anthony lynn
getting run out of the
out of the uh chargers organization hell
he was 12-4 two years ago
john gruden hasn't been 12-4 since
since the year he won the super bowl
yeah
i mike listen it you know what do you
want us
over hyped i'm not going to disagree
with you there
yeah i i you know i don't know why i
think there's a lot of factors hey the
chucky factor he was a young handsome
guy
with the oakland raiders and got them
back on the national scene
gets traded to a team with some you know
huge
transaction involved in that wins the
super bowl
of course has the chucky personality
down there as the super bowl winning
head coach and
you're right all the faces on the
sideline all those things it's easy for
people to talk about latch on to
you know everybody knows who's john
gruden is and then he goes in the booth
and
he was damn good in the booth i mean him
and tarico were as good a watch as it
really gets
so i used to love that and okay
the results have not been you know
astounding but
i still think this is a very good
football coach and i know that
i have maybe have bias because i played
for him but i think i've been pretty
honest about john gruden when i think
things haven't been good i've
i've spoken my heart there and and my
brain as far as that's concerned
but the guys you mentioned he's got a
better record you call it bias you call
it bias i call it stockholm syndrome but
continue please
well i mean he's got a better record
than some of those coaches you talked
about kevin stefanski took over a team
that's more talented than the las vegas
raiders and hey the raiders
they're close you know the other thing
is they play in a division where the
king of the nfl resides and that that's
an issue too
it's not going to be easy necessarily
but i don't think we're anywhere near
that does he get a free pass to like
what you're saying
as far as yes you know he's
a little of a media darling okay i'll
buy that but i don't i'm not in
i don't think we're anywhere near hot
seat or it should be hot seat
conversation
in reality at least for not for me i
think the only difference between him
and rex ryan is he's won a super bowl
and i i just i'm amazed and astounded
and it really hasn't hit me until today
it's kind of like the
the scales have come i've seen you go so
hard
like this yeah well well but but but but
as again if anthony lynn had done for
the last three years as coach of the
raiders
what john gruden has done we'd be saying
get in the hell out of here
if any other coach if any other coach
right now in the nfl other than bill
belichick had done what he's done for
the last three years with the raiders
there would be a much louder chorus
of get him out of here and hire someone
else
uh there would i will agree with that
okay fine
yes but you know again the difference
between rex ryan and him a super bowl
that that's a pretty freaking big deal i
mean it's
it's a big deal i you know i don't know
what else to say there
so that that there is some okay there's
something
though hey in philadelphia they want to
run doug peterson out of town and he won
the super bowl three years ago
when he took the team to the playoffs
the two years after that and they want
to run him out of town
if john gruden was the coach in
philadelphia would they want to run him
out of town
i don't know maybe but that's it's
philadelphia they're a different animal
altogether we know that i mean
we do so uh again i understand it with
gruden
don't with the anthony lynn thing it's
not fair to compare that
i don't think it is anthony lynn you
know you could sit here and argue with
the with the chargers in their 409
record
that five of those losses could just go
on anthony lynn and clock management in
that
john gruden has not had that issue one
time maybe not as
high-flying and awesome with a football
team as we want
but still a lot of good there and
yeah they haven't found their way we'll
see but i'll agree with you on
everything
other than yes i think he's a good coach
and i don't think we're in the hot
hot seat conversation yet
i don't think we are either all i'm
saying is it shouldn't be a forbidden
topic because it feels like it
is it feels like there's this protective
shell around john gruden maybe he was
hey isn't it great i i can't fault the
guy
if you can in an industry
where winning matters and losing gets
you
fired if you can create uh create an
aura
that makes you impervious to that bravo
i you crack the code right
um because he's good on tv because he
gives good quotes
because we think it's funny when he
makes his kind of overgrown dennis the
menace
facial expressions or calvin from calvin
and hobbes remember when calvin would
make the faces and
his mom would say it's going to freeze
that way someday and he said great
right he makes those faces and we think
it's entertaining
and we we couldn't wait for him to come
back to coaching we couldn't wait for it
and and and so we're willing to be we're
willing to be patient
when yeah okay i don't know and and now
we're reaching the blame-shifting
stage of gruden's existence which should
make
everyone in the organization nervous
because paul gunther's already had
the hammer fall on him and i think if
i'm mike mayok i'm looking over my
shoulder and i'm wondering what he says
about me when i walk out of the room now
because is he blaming this on me how
much of his
failure is being thrown at me when i
walk away i think that's a legitimate
question if you're anyone
who's in a position to to catch flack
and take blame for why the raiders
haven't made it to the playoffs
during the three years gruden's been
back if they don't make it this year
he can be brutal that way i mean i'm not
going to deny it i mean yeah
okay we know that he's not the only
coach that's brutal that way either
though i mean that
that's that you know that's just part of
nfl no but they but they get fired if
they lose
right but they get fired that's yeah
well everyone else
everyone else is held to a different
standard than john gruden that's my
overriding point i'm not trying to pick
on john gruden
but yeah and the fact that the fact that
i'm kind of like oh boy am i saying
something i shouldn't say
it's i'm piercing through this candy
coating
that has been wrapped around his
coaching reality
and and i don't get it i don't get i am
awake
i am here i am arrived and i'm saying i
don't get it with john gruden i don't
get it
he made the oakland raiders into a super
bowl contender
he got the tampa bay buccaneers over the
hump to win a super bowl and made them
relevant
for you know five or six years i was
part of one of those playoff runs jeff
garcia
was part of another one of course and
then there's the brad johnson super bowl
run
so for a lot of coaches that'd be pretty
damn good to have on their resume
all right and then he goes yes to the
las vegas raiders
now obviously there was an agreement to
let some things
you know let some time here i need time
to do that
all right yes does maybe he get a little
bit of a free pass as compared to other
coaches
okay i'm not going to disagree but
that's part of like you
said he's cracked the code he's
charismatic he knows how to talk to
people
he knows how to talk ball i'll say this
though like really let's go through this
mike
who's go let's go through the chargers
and raiders roster
like like we could do it real quick you
know quarterback who we going to give
the advantage to i mean
right now maybe i don't know probably
justin herbert
uh really listen i i i'm not going to
argue i'm not we don't have to go
through okay
i will concede to you that the chargers
are a better team
but after three years of being there
three years is an eternity in the nfl
three years is more than enough time to
turn a team around
and even though mike mayok is the gm
john gruden is in
charge of that operation we know that
from the moment he walked through the
door with his 100 million dollar
contract
he's in charge he's the one who's making
the decisions about where they spend
their money
where they spend their draft picks he's
the guy who's doing it
and after three years you can't say
well oh well well blame it on reggie
mackenzie how reggie mckenzie put a
playoff team together
yes well let's see maybe this is a
playoff team this year
well i mean they're on the outside
looking in between your roles
will you feel better well no will you
will you feel better though in three
weeks
if they are in the playoffs to where
it'll change you know won't be
okay all right i didn't know you know
everything all right i'm i'm interested
to do the picks to this week i'm gonna
gambling i might actually gamble if you
know all these answers okay
i've already asked you the question
would you bet your rolls-royce
on the raiders make it to the playoffs
and you said no
now the question is would you i would
adopt that raiders i had a rolls royce
now i'll ask one of my neighbors here in
greenwich connecticut for their rolls
royce
they'll let me gamble yeah right i would
like to tr
take hers but uh you see crazy does she
shovel her own snow
i doubt it i i i don't think that's
going on very often around shovel your
own snow
do you shovel no i don't i'm not gonna
lie and tell you no i do not sorry i pay
people to do that you know what you
charge you know i don't you know why i
don't i don't because it melts
eventually
i let mother nature take care of my snow
chargers dolphins broncos
they can win all three of those games
mike they can win all
three and yeah they might need a little
help and then some other teams to lose
but
they can win all three and maybe have a
chance that last week to sneak into the
playoffs and
we'll play this clip back and um we'll
throw it back in your face and i'll be
like see
john gruden is the man he's a playoff
coach edith florio
if if they make it to the playoffs
he almost was going to say i'll dye my
hair blonde like his but i won't do that
don't i would wear i've got i've got a
raiders
zip up downstairs that i will i will
wear it and i will own it and i will
praise the raiders
and see this is the kind of thing where
and you know we're dealing with
with some cult mentalities beyond
football right now that's all i'm going
to say about that but
don't let yourself as a fan of the
raiders become a member of the cult
you you should demand more than what
you're getting
and just because john gruden is the
coach that's not good enough maybe for
some fans maybe for marc davis
it's good enough we don't have to
contend john gruden's our coach
and he's cool and i get to hang out with
them i don't care if we're seven and
nine
uh all right well fans of the team that
demand something more than what they've
gotten since the raiders went to the
super bowl the year that
they lost to gruden in the buccaneers
and really haven't been
much at all since then i mean that
that's one of the reasons why the
raiders are tolerating
this is it still better than what
they've had for the most part
prior to group sure other than the one
year they went to the playoffs with the
team that reggie mckenzie put together
this is this is you know better overall
than some of the
the horrible years we've seen yeah no
doubt i think that's
that's what i mean that's where i was
talking about when you crapped all over
me before and i said you know john
gruden makes them a little bit more
relevant
he adds to the shininess of them i don't
care if they're in vegas or not
all right so uh there's no doubt and
let's not forget last year seven and
nine it doesn't look that great now but
nobody we didn't expect them to be seven
and nine
and in the playoff conversation early
december last year
so that that was a win of a year right
there too and we can't forget that
you know right now they're reeling
and it hasn't looked good they need to
right the ship in a big way or
the conversation that we're having is
going to become a more com
common conversation this offseason i
could tell you that so that's where this
end of the season is important
to right the ship for you know what's
around gruden the talk all of that and
then
of course a chance to get in the
playoffs if they're not competing
for and achieving a playoff berth next
year john gruden in my mind is
shifting into lyle lanley territory and
fans of the simpsons will know he's the
guy that went down to town
selling monorails and if you can pull it
off
more power to you and if in a highly
competitive
industry like the the national football
league you can remain gainfully employed
as a head coach
based upon performances that would get
any other
coach fired good for you good for you
congratulations john gruden regardless
of wins and losses
you have won
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports